I'm Richard Hammond and I Drive all
sorts cars particularly Porsches and but
there isn't one available on this game
we're about to do
I'm James May I'd like to drive
interesting cars
Jeremy Clarkson I'm an environmentalist
I like bicycles we are about to have a
race on this thing I'm going to drive a
small plastic novelty called ghost
around this cardboard racetrack my car
is called nuke I'm driving an electric
car which is good for the environment
why's it called polar bear which is what
I'm trying to see this come from all of
a sudden ready 15 laps again Matt yes
and blue haha we're going round in a
figure of eight I'm winning that's all
the nose I just shot you both Oh shot
both of you it's cars are quite a bit
smaller than the ones we're already
playing oh this is basically the same
it's exactly the same problem what you
see here feel think remember hopeful
when you like to just do an interview he
just lied on the way through I give most
of my money away to homeless people I
don't think I gave it up me is what is
this what well I learned that breweries
we use it oh for God's sake children get
off me you weirdo
so busy just leave this at full speed
and that's an object yeah so anyway
that's what you do this evening
you drive any faster than that you may
have an accident you children maybe a
chat with is it don't like it you do
know this isn't real then what is
written
I'm just lying my line wedding which is
predictable all right you are honestly
right I'm not I'm just one is what's
happened
oh damn ace I like I'm second the world
I rightly so Daisy the best man won I'm
proud could I say me and this is
important because this is a magazine
about technology that's seriously he's
bombs